it's a double elimination tournament
which is a really rare format
for a chess tournament most chess
tournaments are
swiss or round robin
but this is double elimination
which means
after your second loss you are
eliminated from the tournament
all right cecilia 2006
playing the real lopez from sri lanka
oh no
this is gonna be a tough game we've got
the young indian prodigy
the young
16 year old indian prodigy
and
i guess i guess not indian the sri
lankan prodigy i don't want to offend
anyone
not trying to offend anyone
i acknowledge that they are
different countries so yeah we've got
the
2022 american
cup
that's in april and we've also got the
spring chess classic that's gonna be
hosted here on the st louis chess club
twitch channel
march 1st through march 12th
so definitely be sure to
be here for that as well
a lot of big names in that one females
juniors
strong
players
so
definitely be there tourney time
mountaineer 89 yes
yes okay he's played d3
i think we had a
i had a i had a very recent classical
game with a similar position
but he played d3-1 move earlier and then
he ended up castling much later
we'll play we'll play b5 bishop b3
and
[Music]
what do we want what do we want to do
here
bishop e7 castles or h6
i'm attracted to bishop b7 that was my
first instinct
h6 doesn't feel right but at the same
time i kind of want to prevent this
bishop from hopping into b5 start with
bishop b7
that was my first instinct
just continuing development
i don't think the bishop coming here is
too much of a concern because we're
going to castle play rookie 1 bishop f1
knight e7 and g6 so if the bishop is on
h4 then we're going to be hitting the
bishop like that anyway
so
um
i don't think bishop g5 is actually a
huge concern
we'll castle
and we'll go for the standard plane
knight c3 i'm happy to see that move
because the theory plan states that the
knight should be on g3 or e3 to look at
the f5 square
so i don't
i'm happy to see the knight land on c3
instead
okay i think we're
going to continue developing here
and i'm very happy to see this move
because now he actually can't play this
move just tactically
it's not possible
um
and
is doesn't that fail tactically for a
similar reason
or is he gonna do some weird
queen h5
i don't think it works
takes
takes takes takes queen h5
like
i don't think it's okay
well
i guess he does have the pawn capture
so that is saving his piece so we don't
actually win a piece here unfortunately
but it should be good terms of position
this should be
good
wow
she doesn't go for
the pawn capture
is he
is he winning
more material
takes
takes
my problem is he is this check
and then he can take
and take
wow did i just get absolutely destroyed
here tactically
i think maybe i did
ooh he shouldn't have done that move
though
or maybe
maybe that was his playing all along
i thought pawn takes was stronger
um
but he's actually gonna play queen h5
and
i am gonna be
hurting a lot
so maybe i should play
queen g6
plays this move
here
advances the pawn
hmm
wow
what a strong
this is a really strong player
that is
that is really quite incredible
cethelia 2006
you've got the tactics
pulling out all the stops
where can i put my
king
this move loses to queen h5 i have to
stop
the f7 checkmate so i have to play g6
then queen takes h7 and i can't stop the
checkmate
um
[Music]
so i guess we're coming
to g6
and we're going to try to hide our king
as quickly as possible
that's what we're going to try to do
but yeah he's got queen g4
we have to play bishop g5 sack back the
piece
hmm
[Music]
really funny game here
really
i'm honored
i'm honestly honored to
um to have played this game
because this is a really
incredibly beautiful
game for my opponent in terms of tactics
um
really just in terms of everything
i think we should
probably take that
just for
safety purposes
queen f5 check
like king h6
i'm it's curious that he didn't
recapture but
um
yeah this looks not bad for him either
it doesn't look bad
well now we're maybe getting safe on the
dark squares
so
he may have messed this up
oh i totally forgot about uh
totally forgot about this move
dang it
oh well
cethelia
the uh
like clockwork
like clockwork
good
game good game
definitely
a very very impressive game from our
opponent well good game
good game to our opponent cethylia
they beat us fair and square
and um
they've definitely got a a promising
chess career
they were born in 2006. cythi 2006
what's up man it's nice to play with you
yeah good game
really good game that was an incredible
tactical sequence
so
really really nice job